on est à trois clics des cris de textes
qui sont littéralement des actes de
guerre manuel de guerre d'entraînement
militaire de alors pourquoi elle le
cégep ne pouvait-il pas par prudence
suspendre le contrat avec vous faire
enquête et attendre encore une fois
votre version
je pense avoir été clair ce que
j'expliquais aujourd'hui c'est que le
cours qui se déroulent à l'école les
compagnons n'ont rien à voir avec ses
écrits elle avait un lien sans passagers
parce que je peux au moins expliqué
mauvaise route parce que monsieur a fait
un exposé qui n'a rien à voir avec le
contenu de l'école ce même si trois
clics mme avec deux clics de radio
canada je peux aller dans des discours
d'oussama ben laden je peux faire
l'exposé aussi qu'on ait réduit son vécu
avec un seul on peut googlé un nom il se
retrouvait dans une littérature très
violentes mais ce que nous nous
enseignons c'est un livre sur la base de
la foi
ce temps court d'à peu près qui se
déroulent de 9 heures jusqu'à 14h et le
cours sur la religion c'est 20 minutes
sur un livre qui est clair qu'ils mènent
ce crime qui n'a rien de radical
non mais c'est important de souligner
quand même vous êtes enseignant où il
est enseignant je peux vous enseigner
encore rien vous n'êtes pas d'enseigné
ou johnson ou dans les écoles
secondaires maintenant change rédaction
de thèse de doctorat d'un talent
d'acteur vous êtes enseignant vous êtes
pédagogue vous fait la publicité de
votre de vos cours et sur votre page
il ya un lien un lien qui nous amène
directement aussi équitable n'êtes vous
pas inquiet que votre site donne accès à
des jeunes à des textes qui sont des
actes de guerre et qui sont une
interprétation de l'islam qui est
meurtrière je pense c'est une
interprétation qui est biaisé notre lien
conduit à télécharger un livre sur
lequel va porter un examen qui n'a rien
à voir avec les milliers de livres qui
se retrouvent dans une bibliothèque
virtuelle mais quelle prudence avez vous
montrer en en faisant ce lien à un cheat
extrêmement fréquenté le asian est parmi
les plus populaires avez vous été abusés
jeunesse faire preuve d' avec le bac des
responsabilités moi je pense que les
responsables voulaient parler d'
irresponsabilité
comment se fait-il qu'un jeu
ce fait confisquer le passeport par son
père et qu'il de responsabilité les
responsables sont multiples l'humour
n'est pas un corps policier excusez moi
on n'est pas ici dans ce vaste sujet
enseignants quand il demande à ses
élèves d'aller télécharger le livre ou
d'aller chercher un et dans une
bibliothèque qui n'est pas virtuelle n'a
pas l'obligation morale ni pédagogique
d'aller derrière c'était l'heure pour
voir si j'ai pas téléchargé autre chose
alors est ce qu'on peut dire que les
cégeps à défaut pour vous de prendre vos
responsabilités de pédagogue enseignant
parce que je ne peux t'en défaire de
l'enseignement vous prétendez même faire
de la déradicalisation comment on peut
vous prétendre faire de la
déradicalisation en exposant par un seul
clic
un pet un petit deuxième clic à tous ces
textes qui sont des actes de guerre
encore une fois mais là je réitère ce
que j'ai exposé ce matin nous avons un
cours qui porte sur la leaf x leur êtes
en train de dire que en allant
télécharger le livre x ça se peut il est
probable qu'elle les avait voix d'autres
biens civils
mais si vous quittez les pédagogues
c'est vous qui avait permis d'écoles
d'enseignement et vous prenez ces
risques là où est votre prudent qui veut
te raconter un prof on voit son nom elle
cherchait un livre sur les trente
glorieuses et qui se retrouvent avec un
livre journal guérilla et qui se
radicalise qui me vient une qui devient
extrême gauche c'est le prof qui a la
responsabilité royaume à leur revenons à
l'actualité
revenant à ses textes qu'est l'islam
professé vous ce matin à exprimer de la
colère vous êtes impôts fendeur de
système
pas un seul mot pour le deuil du social
vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous avez 148
on me l'a dit très confiant concernant
les allégations s'il vous plaît vraiment
terminer ma question monsieur charkaoui
si je reviens ce matin vous avez attaqué
les médias vous avez attaqué les partis
politiques vous avez attaqué vous avez
accusé les médias de faire le jeu des
partis politiques vous n'avez je n'ai
jamais entendu dans votre bouche et
j'aimerais l'entendre ce soir une
condamnation aussi virulente que vous
avez fait ce matin de tout le monde au
nom d' islamophobie du groupe armé et à
cela mais qu'est-ce que vous condamnez
le groupe armé islamique
ce que j'ai dit ce matin premièrement
une hollande l'enjeu répondre à la
question oui très bien c'est en train de
mettre des mots dans la bouche
jeudi
vous allez en parler mais je n'ai pas
condamné les médias
j'ai dit que certains médias ont un
agenda politique au québec et se sont
servis de la question identitaire pour
réaliser réaliser leur rêve de pays et
ses médias là on les connaît et madame
lucie match aller en démocratie oui moi
je ne permettrai pas de colporter des
allégations à votre égard je dirais pas
que madame dussault et d'accointance
avec les souverainistes ou les péquistes
comme un journaliste n'a soufflé en
venant ici
ah ouais mais seulement si ce n'est vous
avez créé une fédération chacun je ne
leur ai bien je ne le répèterai
messagerie vous est-ce que ça laissez
moi terminer mais vous vous permettez de
colporter des allégations à droite et à
gauche puis plus farfelues et on faire
un procès sur la place publique de
livres que l'on l'enseignant pas alors
vous avez commencé par exposer des
écrits qui ne regardent pas qu'ils sont
pourquoi j'ai tellement étranger de
notre école
oui là vous nous demandez de nous
justifier sur ses écrits là moi je vous
dis nous enseigne le coran l'arop nous
avons un livre qui s'appelle les
fondements de la foi et se livrent leur
salive qui accepté par la communauté
musulmane par l'ensemble des savants de
l'islam les plus modérés alors s'il vous
plaît ne nous mettez pas une reste habib
ben c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
faire il n'y avait pas d'autre façon
d'avoir ce livre-là cas d'aller sur ce
site qui est très connu pour avoir
l'onglet à l'hidjab il de faire et le
djihad est de faire c'est la réponse à
ma question monsieur chacun oui ce
qu'est ce que je peux vous entendre dire
nous condat nom d'un groupe armé
islamique le temps vous me le demandez
en bois
quand est ce qu est ce que vous le
demander à la fédération des femmes du
québec si on vous demande de vous le
demander à l'organisme qui travaillent
s'affoler sans adresse que vous militez
contre l'islamophobie expliqua vous quel
est le lien entre l'islamophobie
l etat islamique moi je vous dirais que
ce que pense la majeure partie des
musulmans c'est que l'état islamique
c'est une création des américains et
c'est ce que je crois personnellement
mais je n'aime pas et c'est ça je n'ai
pas à l'exposer publiquement est ce que
je crois madame c'est que bush est
entrée en irak pour détruire un pays et
ça conduit à un schisme profond dans la
société irakienne à une opposition armée
entre sunnites et chiites
et ça profite aux gens qui gouvernent
les maîtres du monde comme les appelle
moi
ski qui s'entraînent spolier les
richesses et il a alors fait ce que je
voulais savoir ce que moi je crois qu'il
est cassé c'est ce que je crus des 4 mai
tout comme elle n'avançait pas ces gens
là qui sont qui sont ces gens là ce sont
des gens qui pratiquent ce que leurs
maîtres leur demande de faire c'est qui
ces gens qui achètent ce pétrole ma
réponse je répondais que ça ma question
alors vrai hse pétrole je sais le minot
dollars c'est moi qui ai interview
passionnante harbaoui alors me demander
mon avis personnel web vidéo mais vous
dégoûter le sujet je suis et je voudrais
savoir mon opinion je vous le dis vous
voulez savoir je pense qu'elle est
beaucoup de musulmans qui se sent
peut-être visé par des comportements
islamophobe peut-être se disent ben
c'est pas la communauté d'abord il n'ya
pas de bons joueurs je peux vous
demander au nom de qui vous parlez mais
qui sont visés par des comportements
islamophobes se disent c'est injuste et
qu'on reconnaisse la mob c'est
certainement inacceptable mais dans
votre corps puisque vous militez
tellement pour les droits de la personne
pourquoi ne peut-on pas vous entendre
sur le fait que décapité six de la
barbarie je vais vous citer un grand
philosophe musulman de paris abdennour
bidar qui dit le terrorisme ce n'est pas
l'islam le vrai islam le bon islam qui
ne veut pas dire la guerre mais la paix
et qui est est ce que vous endossez ses
propos mais ce que nous prêchons le
terrorisme sa c5 rhône a annoncé
aujourd'hui
mais pourquoi vous l'avez le cégep
annuler un contrat parce qu'il assure
des lignes en bas c'est ça il suspend un
combat pascalien cours d'une
bibliothèque virtuelle et maintenant
vous sortez un discours sur le
terrorisme mais c'est incroyable mais
j'avais aussi devant vous y avait un
directeur d'une école catholique je vous
parlais tout ce que vous voulez que vous
n'allez pas poser ces questions et c'est
ça exactement l'islamophobie
c'est nous prêter des intentions ensuite
nous demander de nous justifier tout le
temps alors moi je vous le dis à
communauté est allé on ne peut plus
alors ça n'arrête pas
votre manière de faire est inadmissible
on n'a plus à se justifier
ça ne concerne pas on est très loin de
100 alors moi j'avais c'était encore un
abdennour bidar qui dépouillent cela ma
famille et musulmans ils les jambes
d'islamophobe lisait vincent g soeur la
nouvelle islamophobie islamophobes ne
veut pas dire seulement quand on est
quand on n'est pas le musulman qu'on
peut être islamophobe se met alors à la
question je pense est pertinente pour le
contexte actuel puisque vous menacer de
poursuites parce qu'on est suspendu un
contrat qu'on veut votre version et
qu'on cherche c'est normal à prévenir
des la présence de radicaux s'il y en
avait il est indispensable que la face
du monde tu proclames ainsi au fort que
l'islam dénonce la barbarie mais c'est
tout à fait suffisant cinq ans avec
d'énormes ida est ce que vous vous
identifiez à ceux qui veulent réformer
l'islam ce qu'ils veulent
qui veulent réformer l'islam je connais
pas ce monsieur je ne sais pas je ne
pense pas qu'un philosophe puisse
réformer l'islam et dans chaque religion
il ya des fondements
alors est-ce qu'on va demander par
exemple ou juifs de reconnaître que
jésus le fils de dieu ce qu'on va
demander aux chrétiens de réformer le
catholicisme et reconnaître que mahomet
mois ahmed al islam c'est le dernier
prophète
je pense qu'il ya des fonds en bois dans
chaque religion qu'il faut respecter
est-ce que c'est aux problèmes aux gens
du sud et d'asie c'est qu'elle terrorise
les pages du très connu la pire alors
c'est sûr que le terrorisme n'a pas de
religion il ya des terroristes juifs
d'éclat ghana c'est clair vous indigner
passe parce que j'ai un grand sentiment
d'insécurité dans la plupart des pays du
monde et les gens veulent travailler
avec la communauté musulmane pour
contrer ce terrorisme là alors qu'est ce
que vous aimez ça est ce que vous vous
le condamnez le groupe armé fait ça mais
qu'est-ce que vous travaillez à contrer
ces effets ici à la radicalisation
je pense qu'on se répète j'étais hyper
clair j'ai dit que établir en liant une
corrélation autres islamophobie et
terrorisme est faux il n'y a pas un lien
c'est ce que nous plaidons au niveau du
collectif qui est vu comme quand
islamophobie non le demande pas or une
victime de se justifier tout le temps et
nous estimons aujourd'hui que la
communauté musulmane est stigmatisée
d'emblèmes de victimes c'est ce que je
voudrais vous parler au nom de qui ou
lors du collectif québécois contre
l'islam au fait alors j'ai parcouru pas
mal de vos pages la genesis ils ont
failli sur votre site il ya dans
l'esprit plusieurs géante l'islamophobie
le terrorisme parce que c'est le
terrorisme qui peuplaient générer de
d'islamophobie le terrorisme de certains
de certains dérapages de certaines
dérives il nulle part vous condamnez
quoi que ce soit est ce qu'il répond un
pont afin quand les deux val d'allos ce
qui veut dire cette discrimination cette
haine envers les musulmans et la
résultante du terrorisme est-ce qu'on
pose la sq ont dit la même chose par
exemple pour l'antisémitisme est ce
qu'on dit qu'il ya de l'antisémitisme
parce que la communauté juive dans son
sac il ya des éléments radicaux est ce
qu on dit par exemple aujourd'hui que
l'homophobie résulte d'une certaine
violence chez les homosexuels
est ce qu'on parle au niveau du racisme
que s'il ya racisme c'est qu'il ya une
minorité de noirs qui se comporte mal on
ne dit pas pour les autres types de
discrimination mais quand vient le temps
de parler de l'islamophobie
on essaie absolument de nom m il ya une
corrélation entre le terrorisme et
l'islamisme habitat ça nous le refusons
non mais est ce que ça peut aussi vous
servir de paravent cette cause à
quelques os la cantine d'islamophobie
pour mais là vous prêter toutes les
questions je me pose des questions je
n'ai pas démocratiques peuvent poser ces
questions à madame de soi on est en
démocratie et nous sommes transparents
ouais j'ai milité contre les certificats
de sécurité de 2003 jusqu'à 2000 avait
gagné c'est ça et de 2010 j'ai commencé
cette lutte contre l'islamophobie mais
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il aille le
débat très j'irai un débat de près
déchirant au niveau de la société
québécoise sur la charte des valeurs
québécoises
et là on nous a diabolisés lisez notre
mémoire et on a déposé laisse parler
s'il vous plaît lisez notre mémoire
qu'on a déposé à la commission sur la
charte et vous allez voir quels sont les
objectifs du collectif
lisez notre mission arrêtez de parler de
nous mais lisez nous s'il vous plaît
alors si on parle de déradicalisation ça
vous intéresse comme si ch'est bosse je
pense que tout le monde est concerné bon
samedi alors s'ils ont des radicalise
il faut pouvoir dire que ce qui se passe
en syrie avec le groupe armé islamique
et dans le nord de l'irak que ce n'est
pas l'islam que c'est une dérive de
l'islam est ce que c'est un dérivé
laurent si vous voulez mon opinion basta
du collectif mais comment moi je vois
les choses
la veuve haute opinion que je l'avais
votre opinion excellent parce que vous
militez vous êtes contre l'islamophobie
contre les discriminations qui touchent
à la communauté musulmane
il ya une vraie chasse aux sorcières
aujourd'hui au québec on poursuit les
centres communautaires les lieux de
culte les écoles musulmanes
on enquête partout avec des caméras
cachées avec des micros radio canada tva
empire quebecor va bien et gagne la
partie
mon opinion c'est que l'irak qui était
une société assez paisible ses voeux
fracturé par une guerre qui avait pour
objectif d'en mais je voulais avoir mon
opinion je sais moi pourquoi vous
souriez
mais parce que vous m'amenez dans
l'avion vous parlez de démocratie de
respect de l'opinion c'est grâce à
raymond vous avez vous avez un sourire
nabil m je réponds à vos questions et
laissez moi ton temps et a décapité
wallon moi ce que je dis c'est que je
suis contre toute forme de violence que
ce soit des bombardements sur des civils
que ce soit le phosphore blanc qui
brûlent les enfants de gaza que ce soit
les décapitations toute forme de
violence rend est interdite par contre
ce que vous faites madame c'est que vous
condamnez seulement ceux qui se font
bombarder sans parler de ceux qui
bombardent alors c'est ça le problème
le terrorisme à une solution c'est la
justice quand il va y avoir une justice
sur terre y aura plus de violence
mettons qu'il va y avoir des actions
c'est sûr qu'il va y avoir des réactions
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à collaborer
avec les sujets qui ont suspendu pour
respecter le contrat qui dit que vous
devez être en conformité avec les
valeurs de d'enseignement qu'il valeurs
les valeurs qu'elle venait après l'heure
de manger quand je parle de valeurs
est-ce que vous parlez des valeurs de
porter des armes comme les conservateurs
à ottawa
ce sont des valeurs bien canadienne que
de porter des armes est ce que vous
parlez des valeurs de se moquer de
l'autre parce que noah on se moque pas
des autres
la vidéo en question n'avaient rien de
moqueur mais pendant le charlie qui
demande et et charlie tout le monde
pouvait se moquer des deux des autres
religions
et là on nous reproche que la vidéo en
question était un dénigrement d'une
secte au sein de l'islam
nous nous sommes conscients madame que
au niveau des valeurs et des valeurs
universelles
il n'y a pas des valeurs musulmanes ou
québécoises ou arabes
il ya des valeurs universelles et parmi
ces valeurs c'est le respect de l'autre
les limougeauds indique moi moi moi ce
que je remarque c'est quand vous donnez
l'occasion de parler il n'y a pas de
respect parce que vous prêtez des
attentions ce nom vous commencez par
étaler de la littérature qui n'a rien à
voir avec notre école et vous mettez
dans une position où je suis toujours
sur la défensive après vous
krivets charkaoui en colère mais c'est
normal elle prête des intentions pareil
je ne peux pas applaudir et vous sourire
non mes tripes ou qu'ils m'apportent moi
je vous sourire vous disant que ce matin
dans le point de presse vous nous avez
mis au défi de comprendre le lien qu'il
y avait un autre
votre école votre centre un clic vous
êtes pédagogue vous dire le lien que
vous avez peut-être manqué de prudence
il ya un lien le lien c'est que la vache
à quatre pattes et la table à quatre
pattes
donc la vache c'est la fille de la table
c'est ça le lien et le lien c'est un
indiqué qu' on arrive à les équipes
gagnantes de clips comme je disais avec
un seul qu'il pouvait doubler dans la
peau d'un littérature donc il faut
interdire gougaud et à interdire
internet parce que n'importe quel jeune
dans son qui sous sol il peut rentrer
banane et quitte les cliques et y avoir
ce discours est ce que vous êtes dans la
posture de victime
en ce moment victime du slam of obi
mikel si on est contre adil charkaoui
sans poser question son et critiques
vous serez prêt d attention comme vous
nous dites complément poser question ça
veut dire qu'on est content tout les
musulmans
donc on est islamophobe mais là il faut
voir la définition de l'islamophobie
pour le vieux d'islamophobie c'est avant
tout une discrimination
donc c'est une discrimination contre les
musulmans ou quand une personne qui
semble être musulmane donc grosso modo
c'est une question de discrimination
nous luttons contre les discriminations
est allé voir notre mission c'est dans
la même cabine à 1500 lutter contre le
sexisme le racisme l'antisémitisme et
l'islamophobie donc est revenu à la
première manifestation du 14 septembre
que vous avez diabolisé je parle dans
certains médias non mais il y avait un
récit qu des juifs des catholiques des
musulmans des groupes anarchistes mais
ce qui est sorti dans les médias c'est
que pèsent charkaoui a organisé une
manifestation et je trouve saint justin
alcoa avait eu un droit de parole sur
soi on vous a posé des questions on vous
a posé des questions et vous avez votre
cause et jauge on voulait savoir si vous
étiez contre devons parler d'islam et
que les décapitations et cette forme ces
dérives de l'islam comme un cheikh
musulman vous pouvez quand même
en tout ce sont les sous je dis je suis
contre toute forme de violence je suis
contre la russie un bombardement de
civils qui seront tous les jours les
barils qui sont en train de tuer des
milliers de civils par bachar el assad
aussi sage
vous avez pu vous exprimer merci d'être
venus merci